What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
With us today we have football specialist Lassi Hurskainen
Oh nice!
And to celebrate the EURO 2020 we are combining
Ping pong with football!
Let's go, throw it up!
Let's go through the cones!
I don't have a good feeling about this!
YES!!!
Can you do that with a football?
Yes, give me a bigger ball
Time to go through the hoop!
Easy!
You might as well throw it too!
You sure?
- Yeah, yeah!
Okay.
Typical.
Okay Lassi, crossbar challenge
Let's go a little bit further away!
Arrggghh!
How dare you!
Okay Lassi
Time for some doubles
Absolutely!
Here's the racket
I don't need one, thank you!
Level 3, Otto!
Yeah, show me!
Ok, you can decide your level 3
Yea? Ok, where's your car?
Why?
Did it go in?
Yeah, the first one went in!
Huge thanks for joining us today Lassi!
Absolutely!
I was so impressed we were able to come up with so many tricks combining these two sports!
What do you think?
Yeah, let us know what was your favorite!
Hey, last shot!
Go wide!
Okay, okay!
Go, go, go!!
[Evil laughter]
I was so ready for something!